hola muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en español recientemente fue
conmemorado el día internacional de la
mujer indígena pero la lucha por la
reivindicación de derechos que lleva
adelante este sector de la población
mundial y también la preocupación por la
calidad de vida de muchas de ellas no
tienen una fecha concreta están
permanentemente en su agenda por eso nos
acompaña alejandrina pastor hill ella
pertenece al pueblo wiwa que habita en
sierra nevada de santa marta al norte de
colombia es consejera de mujer familia y
generación de la organización nacional
indígena de colombia alejandrina pastor
hill muchísimas gracias por su presencia
en france 24
agradecerle a este programa frank 24 por
tener el honor de escucharme y dirigirme
a muchas voces que me puedan escuchar es
un placer para nosotros le jardín a
muchísimas gracias bueno estamos
atravesando momentos y hace años ya que
sucede esto en lo que las voces de las
mujeres no en distintos lugares a lo
largo del mundo y sobre todo en américa
latina' se alzan para exigir derechos no
para pedir además el fin de la violencia
de género para pedir derechos como la
despenalización del aborto ahora la
mujer indígena está expuesta incluso a
más discriminaciones a más desigualdades
y violencias
puedo decir que quizás sí porque la
misma situación geográfica el idioma
es una de las que nos hace vulnerables y
además la misma situación que vive
colombia y que los territorios indígenas
son muy apetecidos por la riqueza la
riqueza cultural la riqueza ambiental el
agua las minería hoy se encuentran en
los territorios indígenas y creo que eso
nos hace más vulnerable poniéndonos en
desplazamiento que hay muchas familias
que se han desplazado por ejemplo el
caso del choco el caso de la guajira sin
agua el caso de la amazonía es apt
que es muy apetecida por el tema de de
de los árboles no entonces eso nos pone
en riesgo a los pueblos indígenas y más
a las mujeres no las mujeres por su tema
de idioma el tema idiomático es una
barrera para acceder a esa a esos
programas y proyectos dirigidos desde la
misma institucionalidad del estado
colombiano de katrina porque el idioma
es un problema particular
a las mujeres
está sabido que la mayor parte de
guardar el conocimiento las mujeres
mantenemos todavía nuestro vestido
nuestro habla estudian menos las
compañeras indígenas por la misma
situación no hay escuelas muy cercas en
los resguardos es sigue siendo lejos por
ejemplo hay niños que estudian a 3 horas
4 horas no hay colegio bachillerato en
algunas zonas y es muy difícil entonces
toca cruzar ríos donde hay donde no hay
puente por ejemplo y eso si tú no tienes
fuerza que se cree que la niña porque
tiene que caminar esos son barreras para
acceder a esos programas que realmente
te llevan a que se puedan defender tus
derechos tengas el conocimiento adquirir
el conocimiento es verdad entonces eso
hace que se aleje que la niña
la joven no estudie no además por no es
igual estudiar
una persona de afuera una indígena
por ejemplo el caso de d
de la las pruebas de efe no es la misma
no es lo mismo estudiar una indígena que
tiene estas condiciones geográficas la
lejanía verdad que estudiar nos ponen en
pruebas y eso hace que no hay por
ejemplo conexiones en este momento de la
pandemia los pueblos indígenas estamos
en una situación que el estudio estaba
muy lejos muy retirado entonces eso hace
que no está en condiciones no estemos en
igualdad de condiciones
claro el acceso a la educación
claramente es uno de los principales
obstáculos para las mujeres indígenas
tal como usted lo dice ahora como cree
que podría revertirse esta situación no
y que las mujeres indígenas ganen
empoderamiento
bueno hace una leche una lucha constante
por ejemplo hace poco ahorita el 5 para
ese día
se se está conmemorando se sigue
conmemorando este este día para los
pueblos indígenas se ha ganado una lucha
de un decreto de la comisión nacional de
mujeres indígenas que es en todo este
mes de septiembre se sigue celebrando no
para nosotros los pueblos indígenas que
se celebran a nivel mundial para los
pueblos indígenas son acciones concretas
que hemos ganado por ejemplo que haya
una comisión un decreto de la comisión
de mujeres en colombia que podamos
interlocutar y poner la agenda de la
mujer indígena en el escenario del
estado colombiano y también del del
resguardo de los pueblos indígenas para
nosotros es un logro para los cual nos
indígena en colombia
alejandrina hay una red entre los
pueblos indígenas sobre todo entre las
mujeres indígenas de américa latina
están intercomunicadas de alguna manera
toda américa tenemos el enlace
continental de mujeres indígenas donde
estamos periódicamente reuniéndonos y
tejiendo qué es lo que pasa en américa
latina los pueblos indígenas y como
hermanas nos y cómo tejer ese
conocimiento que nos pone en riesgo en
vulnerabilidad las mujeres indígenas no
de toda la vida en yala eso ha sido para
nosotros un espacio de que nos ayuda a
fortalecernos y conocer las dinámicas y
aprender de muchas estrategias que
muchos pueblos utilizan para poder
visibilizar
trabajos que vienen desarrollando a
nivel del abya yala por ejemplo con los
médicos tradicionales nuestras médicas
tradicionales tipo de siembra compartir
semilla eso es para los pueblos
indígenas de gran importancia porque te
lleva te enseña a que en colombia
también los pueblos intercambiemos 115
pueblos indígenas en colombia el último
censo dan autor reconocido nos permite
de cambiar esa semilla esas ideas para
poder garantizar que siguen perviviendo
los 115 pueblos indígenas 65 lenguas se
habla en colombia y quisiéramos que
hubiese hecho los 115 pero ahí va la
lucha de seguir fortaleciendo desde el
abya yala y fortalecerlo mecanismo de
empoderamiento no con nuestra semilla
con nuestros conocimientos con nuestra
manera de organizarnos de nuestra manera
de contar la historia
hablando alejandrina de bueno de estas
relaciones no que establecen entre
pueblos de distintas regiones de américa
latina y también retomando lo que
hablamos al comienzo de la entrevista
cuando mencionábamos que hace años que
en américa latina' las voces de las
mujeres han cobrado una enorme fuerza no
en las calles por ejemplo como decíamos
con reclamos por más igualdad contra la
violencia entre otros como es le jandrín
a la relación entre el movimiento de
mujeres indígenas y el resto de
activistas que no pertenecen a pueblos
originarios hay alguna articulación un
vínculo allí
bueno en colombia hemos estado en la
lucha del movimiento indígena siempre
diciendo que ese enfoque de mujer
familia y generación se tenga en cuenta
no es una lucha constante que estamos
tratando de que el estado nacional lo
acoja porque hay una manera más
colectiva de ver el mundo más colectivo
desde las mujeres no y tratamos de que
se respete esa colectividad esa
cosmovisión de los pueblos indígenas
porque es lo que nos hace ser indígena
ser diferente al otro no esa cosmovisión
eso colectivo
tratamos de que se respeten esas
palabras es esa cosmovisión de los
pueblos y que los demás plataformas y
lucha de las mujeres se tenga en cuenta
para que sigan permitiendo los 115
pueblos indígena que camina la pandemia
ha puesto en evidencia muchísimas
dificultades que ya venían atravesando
mucho
los sectores de la población desde su
experiencia como están atravesando y
como han atravesado las mujeres
indígenas esta crisis sanitaria
cuentos que para las mujeres indígenas
ha sido muy difícil porque no estábamos
preparada a seguir por lo mucho que nos
habían dicho nuestras mayores que toca
cuidar la semilla que toca cuidar la
planta que toca cuidar el conocimiento
es lo que hoy tenemos a la mano
porque están todas las vías cerradas
la gente lo agarra con seriedad las
guardias han cuidados las entradas
nuestros mayores están más concentrados
en sus territorios esto nos ha hecho muy
difícil porque no estábamos preparados
verdad con suficiente semillas con
suficiente árbol y además se suma el
cambio climático que en algunas zonas
nos pone en riesgo además también se
suma la violencia verdad que en el medio
de esta pandemia quédate en tu casa no
salga de tu territorio
muchas veces toca salir en el 9 por
ejemplo de agosto que en el txoko o pasó
de bs de agosto y una niña de 9 años
perdió la vida porque hay
enfrentamientos en los territorios
entonces no es fácil no no es fácil
tener población desplazada tenemos la
población en la cabecera municipal es
cuando todo está cerrado
es una pura realidad y solamente las
cosas caseras que tenemos con nuestra
mayor es lo que nos ha salvado la vida
acá en colombia y en los demás
territorios porque intercambiamos en
latinoamérica y también es igual
alejandrina pastor gene muchísimas
gracias por su presencia en la
entrevista de france 24 ha sido
realmente un placer haberla entrevistado
gracias a ustedes el programa frank 24
por favor gracias a usted a nuestra
audiencia como siempre le invitamos a
continuar informándose en el resto de
nuestra programación y recuerden que
pueden volver a ver esta entrevista y
muchísimas otras más en nuestra página
web france24 puntocom
[Música]
y